haha the Joe Rogan experience that's
another thing that people don't want to
hear no I don't want to hear that but
there's a thrill to shooting I mean
think about it like I got taking some
courses like of course I take in New
Mexico
we're shooting out to 600 sometimes a
thousand meters that's crazy
naughty but so far and it's but it
didn't you also talk about how beautiful
it is people love long-range shooting
they get very addicted I'm giving it
when you get to a thousand yards what's
the amount of time between boom and dink
man it's it's extremely noticeable but
here's which we're really trippy I don't
know the exact seconds because it all
depends on you're talking about
different bullets beats yeah so the
crazy thing is when you're watching it
through your optic you see the paper
trail yes you see the paper trail and
then you see the impact but you don't
hear anything and then you see it think
like a sound travels slower yeah it's
crazy
bullets literally traveling faster than
speed of sound people don't realize that
yeah and that's naughty man and it's and
then you take that you couple that with
being in a beautiful environment oh my
gosh you can't beat it
yeah well I've shot at the range I've
really only shot rifles up to like 200
yards and that you hear boom dink
yeah so there is a difference though
it's not instantaneous yeah and still
get the delay because otherwise you
wouldn't even hear the dink which is how
which is a lot of times is like that's
how suppressors work because people
think suppressors make things super
super super quiet
they really don't what because all the
suppressors are doing is it's it's
mitigating the noise at the muzzle right
and people don't realize that when a
bullet breaks the sound barrier you get
a crack so when you shoot a gun
typically speaking you hearing two
sounds at once you're hearing the bullet
leave the muzzle and then you're hearing
the crack of the bullet break the sound
barrier because traveling that fast so
it's like a cacao but it's happening it
what it sounds like it's happening at
once auditorially boom so when you put a
suppressor on it people are surprised
because once it mitigates the noise at
the muzzle
all you're hearing is the sound of the
action if it's not a bolt action and
then you're hearing the bullet break the
sound barrier right and so it's it's
kind of kind of cool actually when you
hear it now granted you wouldn't want to
do that too much because still damaging
to ears that's what what about a
suppressor with subsonic so that's the
only one where it actually gets really
damn quiet
but the problem is is unless you're
shooting a bolt-action the sound of that
bolt smacking back and forth it's loud
as hell too mm what about a pistol same
thing cuz you get two you get two sound
of the other slide rocking back and
forth so unless you're shooting a
bolt-action you want a good you want to
get as quiet as possible use the bolt
action what's little section with
subsonic round the opposite of a
suppressor is a muzzle brake and I a
rifle with the muzzle break yeah I think
it mitigates the kick yeah but it also
mad yeah because you got cuz you're
you're outside of the cone of the blast
right and so everybody on the side of
you is getting hit by that it's nice man
they're really loud makes shooting a gun
so much more enjoyable yeah it's like
50% less recoil yeah yeah really feels
like so it's like either one compressors
do the same thing surprised mitigate the
recoil to so okay so you can go
suppressor or you can go now and I tell
people all the time the whole suppressor
thing I think that's a that's a health
issue I think so too I think it's
healthy for your ears yeah yeah like
it's loud man like you don't realize you
have this ignorant idea that people
gonna sneak up on people shoes no one's
gonna hear anything
you mean the same way people do with
knives yeah but I mean they think it's
gonna be like the movies yeah it doesn't
happen like now it's not it's pretty
it's like I told you like now I don't
shoot when I shoot suppressed
I still wear ear protection oh yeah like
people realize that like people in my
videos like why are you wearing ear
protection
you're allowed they hunt with
suppressors and they do it out of
courtesy to the other people yeah yeah I
mean look it really would be good for
people if they had suppressors yeah but
it's a thing in California I think
they're totally yeah oh no you can't but
I think it's also an ignorant thing I
think it's been people that don't
understand because you hit ons because
you have people making policies based on
move
right example v's well you know do
defense this is where we actually make
the movies so and well once I buy them
[Applause]